offenes duell um die macht armin laschet
und markus söder erklären ihre
bereitschaft zur kanzlerkandidatur
radikale migrationspolitik beschlossen
die afg will die einwanderung nach
deutschland drastisch beschränken und
erfolg beim rudern der deutsche oliver
zeidler holt bei der em in italien
souverän die goldmedaille
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen bei unseren
nachrichtenüberblick am sonntag mit
norbert könig für den sport einen
kanzlerkandidaten hat die union noch
nicht aber seit heute ist klar beide
parteichefs laschet von der cdu und
söder von der csu wollen wir haben
festgestellt dass wir beide geeignet und
bereit sind sagte söder nach einer
klausur der fraktionsspitze am
nachmittag in berlin
jetzt müsse die frage einvernehmlich und
schnell geklärt werden
als cdu chef hat laschet quasi ein
automatisches zugriffsrecht seine
bereitschaft jetzt also keine
überraschung
auch markus söder wurden ambitionen auf
die kanzlerschaft nachgesagt bis heute
aber war der bayerische
ministerpräsident der frage immer
ausgewichen
trotz besserer umfragewerte jetzt warf
er seinen hut in den ring britta
spiekermann bundeskanzlerin merkel vor
der klausur auf dem weg zur corona
teststation und dann zum
kanzlerkandidaten test der cdu
vorsitzende armin laschet demonstrativ
gut gelaunt aber fast wortlos sein
kontrahent der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder etwas
wortreicher auf die frage ob er heute
seine kandidatur anmelden werde seine
fraktion zahl der union im
reichstagsgebäude söder und laschet
beide empfehlen sich selbst als
kandidatin tauglich berichten teilnehmer
aus der sitzung
so erklärt sich explizit bereit auch
laschet will übernehmen bekommt wohl
indirekt rückendeckung von der kanzlerin
ein offener machtkampf um die
kanzlerkandidatur denen sich die
gegenspieler öffentlich nicht anmerken
lassen wollen süder erklärt
bereit bin zu kandidieren mich dieser
verantwortung zu stellen wenn die cdu
ist die größere schwester das ja ganz
klar
dieses breit unterstützt in dieses
partei und fraktion und die mitglieder
wollen dann ist das für mich dann auch
eine klare sache dass man dann nicht
kneifen darf sondern man muss sich der
verantwortung stellen wenn die cdu aber
eine andere entscheidung treffe werde er
das akzeptieren süder redet auch die
pressekonferenz länger als laschet
laschet zurückhaltender
der cdu-vorsitzende betonte das
gemeinsame der schwesterparteien wir
haben unsere bereitschaft erklärt für
die kanzlerkandidatur anzutreten
und wir haben uns darauf verständigt in
einem guten prozess der beiden parteien
gemeinsam natürlich auch mit der
bundestagsfraktion hier diese gemeinsame
vorstellung zu starten
die richtung in welche richtung geht die
union süden oder laschet morgen tagen
die parteigremien von cdu und csu
es könnte jetzt doch ziemlich schnell
entschieden werden wer als spitzenmann
für die union in den bundestagswahlkampf
zieht ja fragen wer theo koll in berlin
theo das rennen zwischen den beiden
konkurrenten ist also eröffnet wer hat
nun die besseren karten nun die trümpfe
sind unterschiedlich verteilt armin
laschet hat die viel größere partei
hinter sich und damit ja das sogenannte
erstzugriffsrecht das hat markus söder
heute auch deutlich anerkannt wenn die
cdu sich für ihren eigenen vorsitzenden
entscheiden sollte dann werde die csu
das akzeptieren markus söder hingegen
hat den trumpf der deutlich besseren
umfragewerte und auch das vergisst nicht
zu erwähnen für viele in der union ist
es extrem wichtig denn davon könnte
abhängig sein wie gut die union
abschneidet und wie viele wahlkreise
gewonnen werden welcher von diesen
beiden trümpfen am ende wirklich sticht
das entscheidet glaube ich über die
kanzlerkandidatur
aber egal wie die entscheidung ausfällt
ohne kollateralschaden wird es nicht
abgehen oder das dürfte jedenfalls
schwer werden denn beide bewerber sind
ministerpräsidenten eines wichtigen
bundes landes und für beide wäre der
verzicht natürlich ein gesichtsverlust
aber der verlust wäre für markus söder
glaube ich geringer er könnte sich
darauf zurückziehen dass er ja bereit
gewesen wäre aber wenn die größere
schwester die cdu
sich anders entscheidet dann können ja
halt nichts machen der schaden für armin
laschet wäre wohl größer denn er müsste
bei verzicht ja im grunde auf so dass
bessere umfragewerte verweisen und als
neu gewählter cdu-chef wäre er danach
deutlich geschwächt ab sofort dürfte es
jetzt in der union losgehen sich für den
einen oder für den anderen zu
entscheiden eine analyse der situation
von theo koll in berlin vielen dank
dafür
bundesweit einheitliche regeln das ist
das ziel eines verschärften
infektionsschutzgesetzes es soll
möglichst bis freitag durch bundestag
und bundesrat nötig sind die stimmen der
opposition
doch die kritisierte die maßnahmen als
unverhältnismässig vor allem die
nächtliche ausgangssperre
der deutsche landkreistag bezeichnete
den gesetzentwurf als misstrauensvotum
gegenüber ländern und kommunen fehlt
noch der blick auf das
infektionsgeschehen die zahl der
täglichen neuinfektion bewegt sich
weiter auf hohem niveau
die gesundheitsämter meldeten dem
robert-koch-institut 17 1855 neue fälle
zudem wurden innerhalb von 24 stunden
100 vier weitere todesfälle registriert
die bundesweite sieben tage instituts
steigt und liegt aktuell bei 129,2 die
afg will sich mit radikalen forderungen
für den bundestags wahlkampf profilieren
und fordert im wahlprogramm deutschlands
austritt aus der eu deutlich schärfer
auch die position beim thema migration
die einwanderung nach deutschland soll
stark eingeschränkt werden die partei
spricht sich auch gegen jeglichen
familiennachzug für flüchtlinge aus
dresden christiane hübscher eine
aufgeregte beatrix von storch stürmt das
rednerpult sie hat offenbar als einzige
realisiert was hier auf dem parteitag
gerade passiert ist
meine damen und herren wir haben gerade
beschlossen dass migranten die zu uns
kommen wollen und die weniger als 5
millionen euro mitbringen hier nicht
mehr gekommen sind das passiert wenn man
einen riesigen text abstimmt der gar
nicht an der tafel steht keiner hat das
gelesen
wir haben nicht gewusst worüber wir
abgestimmt haben tatsächlich hatte die
ard in dresden in einer flut von
änderungsanträgen gerade mit großer
mehrheit die komplette abschaffung von
migration gefordert außer für
superreiche wortführer für den antrag
war birke gewesen
es geht einzig und allein darum ein
politisches zeichen zu setzen eine
politische botschaft zu setzen die
draußen von unseren wählern wahrgenommen
werden kann als der afg klar wird was
sie da beschlossen hat bricht hektik aus
der antrag wird entschärft und neu
abgestimmt die partei fordert nun nur
noch die begrenzung von zuwanderung
sowie die abschaffung jeglichen
familiennachzugs für flüchtlinge wir
haben damals auch schon im bundestag
gegen den familiennachzug gestimmt und
dementsprechend ist es auch nur
konsequent wenn wir das in unserem
bundestagswahlprogramm niedergelegt
haben die fdp fordert in ihrem
wahlprogramm weiter unter anderem den
deutschen eu austritt die abschaffung
aller masken pflicht die rückkehr zur
wehrpflicht die abschaffung des
rundfunkbeitrags und ein verbot von
minaretten es ist das was die fdp unter
dem slogan deutschland aber normal
versteht und was die partei soeben
einstimmig als wahlprogramm beschlossen
hat der elfte april ist ein tag des
erinnern
heute jährt sich die befreiung der
konzentrationslager buchenwald und
mittelbau-dora zum 76 mal
bundespräsident steinmeier gedachte der
opfer
wer sich nicht erinnerung könne auch
vergessen was geschehen kann
gemeinsam mit thüringens
ministerpräsident ramelow weiter er ein
kunstwerk ein
eine wand aus 6000 holzklötzchen mit
zitaten von überlebenden zum lesen und
mitnehmen so verschwindet allmählich die
wand nicht aber die botschaften
ja und jetzt zu norbert und zum rudern
mit einem rückschlag für den deutschland
achter
denn der deutschland-achter das
flaggschiff erreicht bei den ruder
europameisterschaften in italien nur
platz vier
nach acht em siegen in serie weltmeister
oliver zeidler holt sich dagegen in
varese zum zweiten mal den kontinentalen
titel früh übernimmt zeitler die führung
und kontrolliert in der folge das rennen
der modellathlet aus bayern will den
enttäuschenden vierten platz bei der
letzten europameisterschaft vergessen
machen
faire bedingungen auf dem lago di varese
am südlichen alpenrand während der
deutschland-achter dort als vierter eine
bittere niederlage kassiert lässt
seidler und seiner überlegenheit nie
zweifel aufkommen
souverän der sieg vor dem dänen nissen
und den polen cicek genauso wie dieses
rennen kann und auch die das line up für
so ein olympia-finale ausschauen und
deswegen schon länger zeit
oliver zeidler liegt im plan für sein
großes ziel olympia-gold schalke 04
feiert in der fußball bundesliga den
zweiten saisonsieg der tabellenletzte
gewinnt gegen den fc augsburg mit 1 zu 0
spitzenspiel in der deutschen eishockey
liga zwischen dem tabellenführer der
gruppe süd adler mannheim und dem
spitzenreiter im norden eisbären berlin
die cracks aus der hauptstadt gewinnen
mit viel zeit ein gipfeltreffen mit
hoher trefferquote die eisbären berlin
in weiß im eröffnungsdrittel mit einem
doppelschlag in minute zehn nach der
führung durch fabian dietz trifft nur
wenige sekunden später matt white zum 2
0 dann die entscheidung kurz vor ende
des zweiten drittels das 3 0 durch pater
tomy und im letzten drittel mannheim hat
gerade den torhüter vom eis genommen
matt white zum 4 0 die adler noch mit
den ehrentreffer
berlin aber gewinnt das spitzenspiel
souverän mit 4 zu 1 zum schluss noch der
blick aufs wetter
die neue woche startet im süden und
osten bedeckt und auch mal mit regen
teilweise fällt sogar schnee sonst wird
es wechselnd bewölkt im nordwesten mit
regen schnee und graupelschauern 2 bis
10 grad
das war es von uns schön dass sie dabei
waren